ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas
vlody à travers le monde et j'ai
l'impression que l' aventure m'appelle
cette fois ci en équipage et moi avons
fait cap vers l'afrique du nord pour un
pays chargé de culture et l'histoire le
maroc
c'est plus qu'un simple voyage c'est une
épopée
[Musique]
non
si les crises est fils de course là ça
va pas du tout là à cette époque on
avait le droit de traverser les
frontières
c'était il ya au moins quelques semaines
d'après me retirer ses pac man
[Musique]
notre road trip commence dans un petit
village typique où on s'arrête quelques
instants pour prendre des forces
ça va
allez reprendre la voiture direction fès
winandy fès le nom signifie pioche
parce que selon la légende on aurait
trouvé une pioche à l'emplacement des
premières fondations de la ville
j'ai lu ça dans un livre qui s'appelle
le maroc pour les mules page 2 oui qui
s'il ya des tanneurs mec qui fabrique le
cuir à l'ancien artisan tu vois et ça se
transforme en ceux ci d'avoir ou qu'il y
ait d'autres les bacs blancs c'est pas
un mec de la fiente de piger deux étapes
de première étape c'est à droite
d'honneur choses cachées pour enlever le
point à gauche si la firme des pigeons
la firme des pigeons pour tirer et
aspire à la longueur elle est partie par
la non c'est bon pour la santé
la santé c'est bon pour la santé ça
ouvre l'appétit quand même et y aurait
donc il paraît qu en été c'est encore
plus fort encore plus fort que ça
[Applaudissements]
ah bah tu savais pas que c'était la
porte emblématique de fès la base
m
ici au coeur de fesses on a visité un
atelier de tissage à l'ancienne ils font
tout à la main ou sur des vieilles
machines et le résultat est incroyable
par contre moi suis-je fait pour le
tissage et la culture la réponse est non
c'est hyper compliqué franchement je
sais pas comment ils font les gens là
c'est ça tire dans tous les sens mais
c'est bien foutu
désolé pour moi il arrive comment sais
tu vas bien savoir faire
pourquoi ce que tout le monde regarde la
caméra et on met le générique d'avoir un
job merci beaucoup pour la petite
initiation de tissage là on va découvrir
comment sont confectionnés les vrais
terre cuite et mosaïques marocaines et
ça commence par une méthode très
artisanal ça c'est de l'argile pour
mélanger dans se bat là avec de l'eau et
puis c'est malaxer avec nos pieds
ça c'est la base de la mosaïque mettre
au soleil pour sa tech et on a invité en
fait à essayer de manipuler un peu la
rue poterie quoi un peu comme la
maternelle
[Musique]
je peux dire duras trop bien
ok les gars faut y aller fort pour
guider tout et vous style vous posez une
émotion en fait un super parce que punis
[Musique]
en face à l'étape d'après c'est cuit et
en plus émaillé moines croire comme un
temps à décorer toute une
[Musique]
je suis fasciné par la minutie et la
patience qu'il faut pour faire tout ça
le détail qui a la main avec les petits
burins là
wahou
ma grand mère aurait adoré être là
dedans après une étape incroyable à fès
la capitale spirituelle du maroc riche
de cultures et de traditions
on reprend la route pour un tout autre
délire finie la poterie maintenant on va
surfer la côte atlantique direction et
ça ira
[Musique]
carney normalement lors des vagues de
quatre mètres
habitué à concept est moins nette
[Musique]
fort foehn mois après toutes les
sessions voilà comment une tueuse
[Musique]
merci nous présente les chevaux de sa
ferme familiale dorlote depuis dix ans
c'est un passionné et amoureux des
chevaux là et là cinq ans il est encore
jeune et messager % à 1 pour l'anecdote
moi je suis traumatisé des chevaux parce
que je tombais quand j'étais petit mais
j'essaie de vaincre cette petite phobie
nul en remontant à cheval avec aussi
parce qu'il est grave cool un bon avec
1.4 voilà
c'est vrai parce que le cheval de martin
avec les mêmes pleurs qu'elle sait blanc
pour cheval il est assorti à toi attends
je la suis petit à battre s'appelle le
tien spartacus mois s'appelle outils
mais c'est une femelle
moi c'est un très beau mâle aux élèves
un petit sourire à la caméra
en fait c'est pas du tout une femelle je
me suis trompé on ne dirait pas comme ça
mais entre oti et moi il ya eu un début
de feeling calendar man
ah non ça se voit pas
la tête est mise à prix l'étranger et a
sacré paquet dollars
en territoire apache
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait quinze ans que j'étais pas
monter à cheval
j'étais traumatisé la petite sud de
belley j'étais petit et j'avoue que là
franchement tout va bien confiance merci
j'ai un petit peu le coeur qui bat là
mais ça va sur coup le cheval était très
zen j'ai très peu de charisme sur lui
c'est à dire que c'est lui qui décide si
j'avance à mes mails et cool et donc
yacine tata instagram spécialisé sur les
chevaux on voit ces sacs et qui
s'appelle yacine cavaliers on va mettre
le lien dans les scripts sion et tout
est là je montre le paysage d'essaouira
la beauté de la plage et je fais des bd
des chevaux pour donner un bon image à
notre police a ouvert il ya des bons
endroits pour affronter andy stress et
profiter de la vie
la mini pelle chez vous s'est beaucoup
amusé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
accrue là comme ça c'est les sensations
c'est trop bien
[Musique]
c'est incroyable la meilleure sensation
de ma vue pour l'instant
merci le maroc je suis amoureux de ce
chemin tout paraît qu'une sensation fera
tout est beau magnifique de la note et
attend a déjà fait du cheval
oui j'aime galop 4 mai mais ça fait 20
ans que j'en ai pas fait vraiment
vraiment toi ben ça ne se dit qu'il a
songé aux quatre soit en parle jamais
était pas non mais c'est vrai tu vas
dans le monde du cheval quoi là vous
voyez un petit bonhomme mais ici il ya
un jeu qui se cache toi tu peux parier
sur moi tiercé quarté quinté +
coupet longtemps fait les gars merci à
tous pour voir cette taille est trop
sympa merci aux chevaux voix officielle
oui ça tue ces bombes un magnifique un
jamais vu une aussi belle villa de toute
ma vie je crois
[Musique]
là on est dans la médina d'essaouira qui
est entourée de remparts 6 à une
belgique était occupé par les portugais
anciennement et donc voilà c'est un peu
l'ambiance un type à l'ancienne et et
artisans des vieilles bâtisses on s'y
promène et on découvre
roy le cousin marocain de merlin et là
il ya des prothèses mammaires naturel je
me disais
[Musique]
c'est beau le poisson en général dumas
l'odeur
avec l'art
la mort de briller
comme les chats en fait ici ils ont des
remèdes naturels pour être des pour tous
que c'est par exemple la poutre pour les
gaz pour être août pour apple vient
tallec des graines pour sourire une
infusion avec souris le plus marrant
c'est quand même le viagra touareg
on pourra voir un bon brâkmar pierre
d'alun savane carlin ça c'est excellent
pour la cure anti sueur et pour la
pousse de la barbe ça la preuve d'abord
sur ce qu'on régule de ricin allez tiens
c'est pour la surface sur ça marche
mieux que les déodorants
j'aimais ça honteux je suis vendeur ici
en fait certains endroits de la ville
ont été utilisés comme décor pour game
of thrones
c'est magnifique mais on n'a pas eu le
temps d'y aller donc on angèle
[Musique]
ok les gars leurs tripes continue on
quitte ou et ça ira ont quitté sa où il
ira et là on va en direction de course
appel bon allez y allez pas vous mentir
je mens pas la caméra je suis à cheval
de bois donc j'en paye les frais ce
matin ma tête c'est une sorte de dégoût
en fait
[Musique]
sarah s'attarde pas trop les manches en
voiture toutes les deux heures la pause
s'impose du coup on s'arrêter très
précisément quelque part au milieu du
désert
ces belges moi je suis belge le sol et
beige
on est à beige landes feu je peux
montrer marta qui a ramené son écoute et
or qui sait dire que elle pense qu'à une
chose c'est manger son petit et or qui
toujours fidèle à ses origines
peu importe si on est sur le globe
l'odeur est maintenant la m jodie
charlotte prana yoga m'invite à aligner
les chakras pour être en phase avec mon
- intérieur normal quoi
tu es un arbre super main prière au
caire par festoient légèrement inspire
et expire au monde et on peut tous
relâchés a refait et maintenant namasté
nombre de grandes planches et une
dernière fois inspire grand cobras
on va t elle a réussi à me transmettre
sa zénitude charlotte là je me sens
vraiment très très zen tu mettais coude
à l'avant ici là c'est la largeur de
técou dit bouge plus tu fais juste ça tu
marches moi je suis derrière et tu
montes tu crois que ton pied juste là où
après l'autre orteils la dentelle il
court tout seul toit c'est en fait ils
ont des petites jambes
elle désire ont commencé les fesses sur
les genoux parfait tu te sens bien là
encore encore parfait super guengueng m
[Musique]
ça a été ou pas ouais
est ce que tu sens qu'il ira voir un peu
le déclic were génial je suis un
québécois et c'est un déclic de ma
cervicales remercie bon petit cours de
yoga l'a3 que c'est mon premier
j'ai encore envie de mettre à l'envers
beaupré pour une station à quad et de
guy savard et d extrêmement sec
[Musique]
thurella vue légal et insein j'ai quand
même dégoûtés ici au sommet du monde au
maroc dans le désert d'avoir ce style ça
gâche tout en fait
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nouvelle destination là je
filme depuis notre jet privé et je
déconne c'est un plan aux drones
j'adore déconner moi c'est abusé on est
à casablanca la plus grande ville du
maroc en population c'est la capitale
économique d'une ville le ouf dabaya la
mosquée de casablanca qui est la plus
grande d'afrique et c'est magnifique
c'est juste géant et tout est blanc et à
les palmiers partout voilà j'ai les
lunettes ce que je vois rien du tout ici
un soleil de malades donc si je les
enlève
j'ai fait ça pour toute la vidéo donc en
plus ça sent un peu un peu cool
donc on est un petit peu les tour du
propriétaire ici ils ont une passion
parabole qui tous les toits ya soixante
mille parabole
on dirait les gens ils ont une parabole
par chaîne d'ailleurs je pense que cette
parabole capte uniquement fort boyard
vous savez qu'on va rencontrer youtuber
marocain ce qu'elle s'appelle simon un
million cinq d'abonnés puisque toi en
fait comment il a pris ce temps à
rigoler des optiques plus beau et tout
beau c'est un vans et de piquer tout le
monde un peu plus vu que ton dernier
gaming la jamaïque où cet avis et ali ou
enron des vidéos alliés jal et all c'est
cool de savoir comment ils travaillent
ici comment ils font pour leurs projets
tous issus de la démerde comme nous au
début si l'on en croit tisser organisé
tout il nous a invités à manger chez lui
à six mois bonjour d'autres termes vous
allez bien fait plaisir car ça fait
combien de temps que sur youtube dupuis
2013 ok
un peu avant l'audience de moi je
profite et franchement j'ai commencé
j'ai commencé ce qu'ils m'ont inspiré
ccbbo la génération c pour ça je suis
très content ça adro le métier qu'on
fait un tu connais bien ça donc ça a
évolué presque d'un bout à l'autre ça
évolue ça change entre la borie entre le
les modes et tout donc les gens parlent
un peu autour de moi des fois j'ai
l'impression de pas vraiment rose métier
que je moi j'aime bien concevoir des
trucs de des conseils trucs marrants
faire des échanges d'idées c'est ce que
je préfère donc peu importe la forme que
ça prend
et au moins ça fait quoi un papa c'est
la pire décision est prise par des
terroristes
nous sommes une famille soudée obama qui
a décidé du prénom
aussi nous deux il a fallu une petite
anecdote racontée par exemple celle sur
laquelle acceptez donc franchement pour
moi c'était la panique j'ai l'impression
qu'il n'y aurait jamais de près mais
monfils l'a rappelé sur titres algérien
algérien est normal et par là même sa
non j'ai des fois des petits mots
prononcés très vite gravi très vite
voler sa drôle parce que surtout les
français savent pas quand bien même on
ne parle à trancher pourquoi pour nous
préparer pour la chance de trois roues
[Musique]
ah non ça fusait la latte à ses
intentions après on va manger
le truc fait cinq ans qu'ils s'opposent
pas au restaurant est vraiment chez des
vrais marocains fait avec amour
on va pousser ça et ça n'a pas marché
[Musique]
ici avec le couscous
ils boivent le fameux elle bonne une
sorte de lait fermenté
disons que le goût m'a surpris graphique
c'est un battant
[Applaudissements]
surrender aida prendrais bien un skate
pensent que leur demande instruite
[Musique]
à ce moment là je me trouvais vraiment
stylé et en fait pas au bon je suis
soufflé et les pzero figure c'est ça le
en trois ans youtube sont robbins bon
après un bon ride moi j'ai toujours à la
mosquée il va alors se dirige vers la
mosquée hassan ii qui est la mosquée de
casablanca qui est l'une des plus
grandes du monde
luminary était plus de 210 m c'est un
droit qui est sublime qui peut
accueillir plus de cent cinq mille
personnes qui prient en même temps
c'est un truc de ouf et en plus elle est
carrément au bord de l'océan dans quel
état qui viennent s'échouer contre la
mosquée c'est à voir franchement ça va
c'est un lieu qui
des charges et tu vas avec d'énergie et
je suis pas musulman toi mais sans
qu'ils montrent qu'ils portent ici ça
un petit
[Musique]
les a mis là on va rencontrer un copain
marocain à moi qui habite à casablanca
et en fait c'est un artiste qui a fait
certaines des illustrations des
miniatures de mes vidéos notamment le
bug des 10 millions il est super fort et
je n'ai jamais rencontré en vrai parce
que je viens pas tous les jours à quai
sans blaquart liait
regardez ce tracé sur la première
spéciale c'est la première à huawei tous
les trucs dans la galerie à oui c'est
vrai c'était dingue ça en gros j'ai mis
une simple story sur install ça me fait
une capture d'écran du truc
il fait une sorte de poulpes géants à ta
dessinée ça en dix minutes
[Musique]
on a passé un petit moment trop cool
avec ça mis à faire des dessins à
prendre le thé et au bout d'un moment je
me suis cassé en direction de la
dernière étape de notre loi soulève
comment ça va la gopro là
[Musique]
mec ça y est on y est on est à marrakech
la ville rouge au milieu du désert c'est
sans doute la ville la plus connue du
maroc c'est un truc de ouf
à peine arrivé il ya une ambiance de
malade on va rencontrer plein de gens
inspirants sans l'on va découvrir la
ville let's go
là on est en train de préparer un petit
jeu on va tous tirer nos prénoms au sort
pour s'offrir des cadeaux ce soir qu'on
aura été fidèle à médina on a un budget
et chacun le conte s'agrandir 50 dirhams
et évidemment on a le droit à la
négociation où on verra ça va bien
négocier watsa mais je me sens bien pour
moi 2 3
[Musique]
shaw 3 2 1
au moment
en
[Musique]
c'est pas dangereux mais ça m'intéresse
beaucoup en fait non
comment
quand deux gazelles un très très grand
classique et ici c'est authentique
voilà
deux kilos en gâteau non à marrakech les
odeurs sont incroyables j'ai été attiré
par un stand de menthe fraîche et vu que
je sais que tu y touche adore le thé à
la menthe je lui ai pris un petit
bouquet pour le jeu et puis en fait
j'avais pas trop d'autres idées donc ça
tombait très bien à marseille
alors ici dans la médina les les
commerçants ils ont des techniques pour
talent bagues etc alors ils font du
bruit avec des pièces où il fit des mots
pour te surprendre tu vois pour que je
suis à regarder potentiellement tu
achètes voilà j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté
les babouches
là mais je veux tout
c'est parfois long
ok
[Musique]
la maladie a fait passer les scooters
les voitures les trains pour les
véhicules en fait aucun problème
[Musique]
pantacourt
on va chez le coiffeur et moi je vais
chez jacques dessange à paris bah oui
c'est ça j'y vais passer sur un accord
chaque échec et guy jacquet qui va te
couper aller lamballe bomberman il avait
une coupe des glaces
voilà mais dans un coiffeur mais c'est
vraiment un tout petit coiffeur
ces trois là ça part en mode kevin
tuning
[Musique]
voilà
c'est validé ça lui va bien
bon les gars j'ai perdu j'ai plus
d'arguments je passe à la casserole
mais on pas bien mais tant commentaire
dans ma vie
l'attend
[Applaudissements]
à
les amis et justement à trouver un
cadeau dans le temps la partie de 30
minutes
oui avec un maximum de 50 kg am oui même
mois parfois huawei s'est gardé un petit
peu des trucs dans sa poche et à des
babouches offrir des babouches arabe ses
origines merci à son goût alors ça c'est
pour guy et l'arrêt du thé à la menthe
[Rires]
persil bocaux de verre dans le groupe
blanc crée une bouchée du canada a un
peu été génial on a pris un plaisir
d'avoir une influence hier aux marques
pour le moment je suis tombé après dubaï
ok tu fais plus des trucs sur instagram
instagram youtube facebook mais là on va
en parler on délit jambes allaient
connaître parler en français il veut
absolument le chinois han d'elijah
c'est-à-dire rôle marocaine en fait ok
faut là où il n y connais ni ça a fait
saint georges serre la sll il attend
mais tu fait un truc à elle a croisé
deux machines
c'est un peu dur le premier regard petit
à petit l'oiseau fait son nid
c'est une expression mapper en garde bon
j'ai un petit cadeau pour toi
waouh trop bien cette issue c'est
vraiment ballot me battais offic savez
bacau fictive n'a pas dit c'est qu'ici
c'est un lieu qui nous a conseillé mme
bernadac camara qui l a très vite dérivé
sur un petit chant traditionnel j'ai pas
pour ce qu'il fallait dire où il fallait
faire et je crois que ça se voit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas on était tous là à chanter à
danser
est ce que je retiendrai de ce pays
c'est vraiment l'authenticité la culture
vivante
les gens vrais et la générosité est
toujours un accueil exceptionnel partout
[Musique]
les amis c'est ici cette petite ruelle
de marrakech qui se termine ce tournage
incroyable pendant une semaine
bon il ya des dégâts par vous mentir
mais je pensais souvenir inoubliable
j'ai passé un pur moment et que tous mes
copains j'ai appris plein de choses j'ai
découvert plein de choses j'ai rencontré
plein de gens malheureusement j'ai pas
pu mais tout le monde dans la vidéo
tellement n'a fait de rencontre mais n'a
une bonne partie donc merci à tous les
gens qui ont pu à qui on fait en sorte
cette vidéo puisse exister surtout
l'office du tourisme du maroc qui nous a
invités de la donner les moyens de faire
ce blog
évidemment je vous recommande si un jour
vous en avez la chance c'est l'occasion
de venir au maroc est un pays incroyable
mettez un pouce en l'air abonnés voir la
chaîne youtube et à très très bientôt
c'est vrai comme
[Musique]